im Moment läuft sie im Radio rauf und
runter mit ihrem Titel mirror Natalia
Kills und sie ist in Deutschland und
zwar tritt sie jetzt als voract von den
Black Eyed Peas in Düsseldorf auf und
für uns eine einmalige Gelegenheit sie
vor die Kamera zu kriegen und für euch
die einmalige Gelegenheit ihr eure
nutzerfragen zu stellen es wird ja
inzwischen schon passiviert ihr wisst es
seid kreativ schaut in den Infotext und
stellt am besten Video Fragen die ihr
z.B mit dem Link hier unten im Video
posten kennt könnt oder einen
Kommentarfeld klicken und rechts daneben
ist dann der Button um Video Fragen bei
Youtube heißen die Video Antworten
hochladen wenn Sie kreativ sind dann
drücke ich äh nein dann kann ich euch
fast versprechen dass Sie dran kommen
also haut rein